oggi seconda parte di indovina chi onora
con tutti i personaggi come grenier lo
nei voli gelataio ribaldi il pagliaccio
malefica mister mit delle ndrine torna
sono tantissimi stavolta però alle 3 di
notte se vedete una luce strana dietro
vitale e questo libro che fa tutte le
luci colorate e poi c'è anche la la
palette please solo che non sia ancora
riscaldata quindi non solo è tutta la
freddo mi piace se volete altre
challenge horror inquietanti alle 3 di
notte
questa volta però noi non diremo che
personaggio abbiamo scelto dovrete
indovinarlo poeticamente noi faremo le
pari domande sapete come gli ovina kit e
voi nei commenti dovrete indovinare chi
è il mio personaggio o quello di vitale
o entrambi prima che noi lo sveliamo
risi state bene attenti a tutte le
domande tutti gli indizi
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn
ioan damir e adesso cosa si potrebbe
essere questo periodo natalizio le
castagne o la cioccolata calda
iniziamo subito è il quarto di
personaggi ma tanto di avrebbe già visti
dall'altra challenge io ho già scelto ma
non vi posso dire chi perché dovrete
indovinarlo io ho scelto e siamo pronti
a cominciare azienda dammi pure la prima
domanda allora il tuo personaggio ai
capelli rossi no no non è che per il
volatile quindi tutti quelli che hanno i
capelli rossi li mettiamo giochi infatti
i toni wise poi i white del 90 e basta
così cielo neighbor forse che c'hai i
capelli un po rossicci
che siano castanicoli livello nei board
non è lo nego la mia domanda per il
personaggio e agli occhi neri si ok
allora togliamo tutti quelli con senza
occhi neri quindi elimina gli occhi
rossi
ciò che l'io che celesti e gelosie
merdith incolore a luke non si capisce è
bravo
annabelle non si capisce bene la moglie
dice agli occhi celesti giocherà gli
occhi celesti so l'enigmista gli occhi
rossi voldemort agli occhi celesti
samara penso che abbia gli occhi celesti
penny wise agli occhi gialli freddi
perché ci riavvia celesti confermate sia
giochi cinesi ma a me sembra che celebra
celesti poi la ndrina gli occhi rossi
tra colazioni e nei malefica gli occhi
celesti il nonno gli occhi bianchi
caspita ma ho fatto una domanda non 2
altica e poi qua allora il grip non sono
sicura di colore abbia gli occhi
sinceramente it agli occhi gialli e
grani agli occhi bianchi per cento che a
me adesso voglio chiederti se il
personaggio in questione ha il trucco
bianco in faccia
no non ha il trucco bianco in faccia
quindi togliamo il gelataio togliamo
volvo togliamo joker
credo che volte mor però sia proprio
così non abbia il trucco in faccia saw
l'enigmista altro con bianco in faccia
la ndrina ha il tocco bianco in faccia
drago la il fuoco bianco in faccia
blender man non ha il trucco magnetica
secondo me era il trucco bianco in
faccia un pochino meglio questa domanda
allora la mia domanda è è un personaggio
cattivo con i bambini
no no quindi togliamo il gelataio perché
sapete che il cattivo con i bambini e
baldi lo stesso di servizio mi sembra
che fosse cattivo con tutti bridge solo
con i bambini
il lupo un po tutti può essere insomma
questi penso che siano un po con tutti i
cattivi e un pupazzo no non è un
paradiso comune altro pazzo
allora facilissimo basi no grinch no
freddi no slimer roses ulime rubat
quindi no poi c'è annabelle che anche
una bambola quindi si è anche la moglie
di ciò che è bianco
ok credo di essere a buon punto quelli
che mi sono rimasti ti chiedo
ai capelli si ok allora cerchiamo slider
mail perché non ai castelli mister mite
non ai fratelli perché ci sono i suoi
capelli dello slider ovviamente non ai
castelli è il numero dei capelli perché
li ha rubati alla ronda almeno credo ap
rossi sono i capelli con vabbè lasciamo
tutti questi hanno i capelli quindi ne
sono rimasti solo quattro ovviamente poi
provate a indovinare chi può essere di
questi l'ora in base ai personaggi che
mi sono rimasti credo di aver intuito
quale esce altro turno quindi la mia
domanda sarà questo personaggio ha gli
occhi rossi
no non ha gli occhi rossi
io pensavo fosse io pensavo fosse lei
quindi no via terina ed è l'unica con
gli occhi rossi non è stata molto
interessante questo grande amore la mia
domanda è non so come vediamo
ai capelli neri si ok allora torniamo
annabelle perché ce n'è a biondi o rossi
si è il lupo cilea tipo castani questi
possono essere oltre a cola ma aspetto
al prossimo turno provare a indovinare
perché non voglio perdere ma sono 230
mila in questo comando l'attenzione
perché foro e vincere devi fare una
domanda che ti elimina dalla maggior
parte dei personaggi omaggio ai capelli
neri si può quindi credo di aver salvato
voldemort
non cediamo strand arment non ce li ha e
lo nei board non c'è la neri granny
forse dice ranieri
mister metterà celia il lupo non c'è la
mary il nonno non ce l'hai neri o cui
provare a indovinare
però questo è sbagliato perdi si propone
di tornare perché mai allora secondo me
il personaggio che deve indovinare la
vita è samara no sbaglia
possibile che mi sono rimaste solo
samara qui e grilli vuol dire che hai
sbagliato ad abbassare qualche
castellini su personale il mio
personaggio era un malefica e malefica
non ha la faccia tinta di bianco ma lei
è bianca di carne giorni
ho sbagliato a quella domanda toccate
adesso indovinare mi basta solo una
domanda ai denti da vampiro
si no i due personaggi erano trappola e
vediamo se rito malefica ormai a sanremo
proprio a fianco mark in effetti
sarebbero molto bene fidanzati trappole
male davvero
scrivete nei commenti nostri meriti
danzati dracula e malefica ho vinto il
primo turno per il secondo turno non
saremo noi a sceglierli ma dovremo
puntare a caso una casellina e qualsiasi
persona tacessi a sarà il nostro
personaggio questa volta voi saprete chi
è il personaggio così potete vedere
insomma chi si avvicina di più pronti
allora tutti ha detto che berlino torna
nel frattempo io punto a calcio con gli
occhi chiusi
angelica cambiate ok di puntare a casa
con gli occhi chiusi e poi altri la
cartella fanno puntare a casa voglio
chiusi ok allora non lo so niente
riprovo questo che abbiamo qui ok ha
fatto che allora tiriamo su tutte le
caselline che questa volta inizio io
allora la mia domanda è è un adulto si
ok allora togliamo chucky che piccolo
anche alla pelle la moglie di giochi
diver anche se non è un essere umano
potrebbe comunque essere uno ad uno
poi c'è di piccolo qua basta un altolà
volte su tre cardelli è il gelataio
secondo te è piccolo grande secondo me è
grande e una donna
no non è una donna quindi via malefica
poli via sull'unhcr in a via g e la
modifica kiem aperte widmann e samara
non male questa volta allora la mia
domanda è a un potere magico
no quindi
voldemort ha un potere magico il clown
potere magico salentina non sono sicuro
che sia magica malefica il lupo non è
magico grenet nel magico ict e magico
intelligenza magica non mi ricordo bene
abbiamo tolto un pochino almeno allora
in base ai personaggi che ho qui ti
voglio chiedere questo personaggio e
pelato se è velato quindi giocano i
capelli tetti di ai capelli crediti di
freddy lo lascia in forza perché forse
si può intendere così perché la domanda
era pelato sacchi ai capelli
il gelataio ai capelli lo slime rai che
per le sole nate mistake it via e lo
neighbor il grinch ai caselli lights
lander man ai capelli e mister mi
tebaldi amiche quindi lupo i capelli
nonno rita fulantelli rimasto solo se
il sacco di caselline li stavano
importando questa volta allora la mia
domanda è è un essere umano
si ok allora sentiamolo slimer cediamo
freddi togliamo il gelataio anche messo
mano sito professione
togliamo il lupo è togliamo il grinch
oddio baldi non so se proprio un essere
umano
vabbè lasciamo lo si potrebbe essere
allora la mia domanda è è un pupazzo no
non è un pupazzo
quindi via 3 b b è il gelataio strymer
può essere considerato un pupazzo
punizione messi quindi rimangono solo 4
hanno anche baldi un pupazzo
ok la vitalità per vincere devo fare una
buona domanda allora la mia domanda è
il vestito o vestita di nero
no allora togliamo le dinamiche del sito
di nero vestito di nero dracula vestito
di nero st marano nebbia o basta avuto
troppi balzaretti ad esse dominerà
vitale il tuo personaggio alla bocca
chiusa
ma chi è il mio personaggio è la bocca
si no non ha la bocca chiusa quindi
voldemort alla bocca chiusa slider ma
non apro la porta non ci fa ce l'ho
fatta intervistare viziano neanche detto
che provare ad indovinare anche tu
[Musica]
allora in base a questi che secondo me
potrebbe essere la ndrina
no no il nonno grendi è lo nego no
baldi no giocher no non è possibile li
ho detti tutti mister mite non ci posso
credere infatti a caso non avrei mai
indovinato proprio perché avrebbe stato
non è possibile che abbia di altre
persone siamo nel perimetro ti facciamo
le domande diciamo ma com'è possibile
che mister matter rimasto ancora in
piedi sono in due posizioni diverse
nostro nella stessa posizione
mister mi ero lì protagonisti proprio di
festeggiare con il sondaggio su cui
eravate riusciti ad indovinare nella
prima sala è nella seconda challenge mi
raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace
insegna che si furini commenti che altre
challenge volete che facciamo alle 3 di
notte consigliate sole tutte qua e aromi
lasciamo 4 caselline su cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che vorrà ferita revisione